a factor because the critical moments
are still ahead in this game Magnus will
ask some difficult questions and wow he
does go for this we said this was a
blunder but he's relying on sacrificing
his Queen Liam
surely he didn't miss this move the Rook
coming across
he has to give up his Queen we said that
this was losing but does he really
believe that he can build a fortress
here how can you hold this position when
you have such a weak Pawn when you're
rook and Knight is so disconnected
maybe he's evaluated this better than us
but uh it would be a shock now to me if
he can hold the draw
it's only two results now it's either
white winning or a draw black has to
somehow curl up into a ball he has to
somehow Retreat his Rook maybe to defend
and cross his fingers and hope wow that
to me this is the Magnus effect because
in the the position until he played this
queen sacrifice I mean everything was
fine he he didn't have any problems but
I mean I have to say I do like Liam's
last move using all his